hey what's up guys my name is trying to
welcome back to my game mansion series
so last time we took a look at
refactoring everything moving it from
our application class into sandbox so
that we could actually have it you know
kind of game application rather than
we'll have all this rendering code and
all this interaction code in our actual
just hazel application as a part of the
API because that's weird
so definitely check out that video if
you haven't already that's a fun little
um description of last video anyway
today we're gonna be talking about a
problem that we had in the last episode
we really see the problem so I'll just
highlight the problem by showing you
guys again what's wrong but basically
what we're doing is we're moving we're
actually interacting with our game using
the arrow keys we're moving the camera
however that movement basically gets
applied everytime we render a new frame
every time we update our app we move our
camera by like what was it I think 0.1
right units every time we actually like
if the arrow key is pressed and we run
into an application update as part of
our update loop we move the camera 0.1
units now the problem with that is who's
to say how fast our application has been
updated right it could be updated 60
times a second it could be updated 20
times a second if like our frame rate is
low and we're lacking it could be
updated 144 times a second if we're
vsync to a 1 144 thoughts monitor or it
could be completely like basing could be
turned off we could be uncapped it could
be running at 4000 frames per second
obviously in that case our cameras going
to move if we're running 4000 frames per
second then we're moving 0.1 units per
frame the camera is moving so from one
units per frame it's gonna move 400
units in one second whereas if we're
running 60 times per second and we move
the camera 0.1 units everytime then it's
gonna be a lot less than that
right something gonna move like six
units per second it's good it was huge
difference 16 is 400 units crazy right
what we want to do is make our camera
move the same speed no matter what right
we want to bake this is actually a
different way of just saying that we
want our movement to be time-based
rather than like CPU frequency based
right so we don't want it to move as
fast as I can get as capable of doing
which
a lot of times that's what we want if
we're doing some mathematical
calculation we don't want it to take one
second to calculate we wanted to do it
as fast as possible but with this we
actually want this thing to just take a
second right or to take like a half a
second you know one and a half seconds
however long that's supposed to go for
that's super important and the way that
we're gonna do that is by basically
tying our movement into real-world time
and we accomplished that by implementing
something called a time step or Delta
time essentially you know engine if you
guys on supporting series pay for an
icon for search the Turner is a great
way to help support all this stuff huge
thank you as always to all the patrons
that made this series possible if you go
there and support the series we get
plenty of rewards such as access to like
little planning Channel and discord and
week and ask me questions and other
patients questions and stuff like that
it really is a good time you also get
videos early and access to eight hazel
development branch in which I've done
all this stuff and I'm talking about
today anyway let's jump in and take a
look at what this Delta time thing is
and in fact my just explain it first
that might help so Delta time the reason
it's called Delta time you might have
heard of that or might be called a time
step basically I know the way this is
gonna work the way that we're gonna move
the camera by a certain amount it's
gonna be like fairly simple all we're
gonna do is we're gonna see how long the
last frame took right so in other words
if we're running at CC x per second then
the frames going to take 16 milliseconds
right so 16 milliseconds real-world time
passes if we're running you know at 30
frames per second then 33 milliseconds
passes right different units different
units of time actually passed so we're
gonna measure that we're gonna measure
how long a frame takes and then we're
actually going to propagate that number
that duration into all of our update
functions so we're going to basically
have a parameter on our update function
that is going to let us know how long
that frame took and then from that what
we can do is actually move our character
by ax or our camera in this case a
certain amount that is respective to
that actual time now the reason that
works and the reason that's important is
as follows because you know what I'm
just gonna draw a diagram because I'm
waving my hands okay sir Delta time or
time step or whatever let's talk about
how all of this stuff works so
essentially the reason that we want that
number right from this from this Delta
time from this measurement of how long a
frame took we could get a number such as
let's just say 16 milliseconds right but
we'll actually do this in terms of
seconds so 0.016 right that's our time
for learning if we're running at 60 FPS
so I'll kind of write two possible
values here and for 30fps if I screw
that up
30 FPS we'll say that our time our Delta
time was 0.03 three or something like
that right so that's our kind of time
values right in seconds so that's what
we'll be kind of pushing into our on
update function now why are we doing
that and how is it going to be used well
what we're actually going to do is take
this time value of how much time has
passed between our frames and multiply
it with our movement velocity our
movement speed right so the reason
that's done is because let's just say
that best way oh sure this is just an
example we have this cube right we have
this square it's moving this way artists
at a certain speed right if we wanted to
move from the left side of the screen to
the right side of the screen in exactly
one second right how many times does it
need to move well if we're running at 60
frames per second then clearly we need
to perform 60 little movements right to
get to here now if we're running at 30
frames per second we need to do half of
that we only have 30 frames to get from
here to here and that is how many frames
were able to render in one second
real-world time so what we need to do is
obviously move twice as far every frame
because instead of rendering like one
frame here one frame here one frame here
we end up rendering you know the first
frame here and then the next frame here
right so we might only render this many
frames
whereas if we're running it twice the
frame rate we have to render the frames
in between as well
this obviously creates a smoother motion
and that's why monitors that are like
144 Hertz you can really tell the
difference even if you just move the
mouse button because it's actually just
rendering more friends and if you look
at an animation it's rendering more
frames in the animation which means that
everything is actually moving more often
right instead of this cube moving four
times in a second it might move eight
times in a second right and that's kind
of what we see here in fact that's why
you can also tell the difference between
like 30 frames per second and 60 frames
per second it's a huge difference of
smoothness right because you're
rendering way more frames it's less
choppy it's more smooth that's what we
kind of want to do so what we do is we
say that our movement is I don't know
let's just say one unit right we move
one unit right we take that and we
multiply it by our delta time right in
this case because just one if we
multiply one by this we get zero point
zero one six which means that our cube
or our object moves 0.01 six units to
the right in that frame whereas if we're
running at 30fps
it moves zero point zero zero no sorry
zero point zero three three units in one
frame that's like double right so it
moves twice as far why because it moves
less often and we obviously want to get
from point A to point B in the same
amount of real-world time which is one
second so that's how this whole thing
works mathematically it's really it's a
really simple concept a lot of people
avoid this and do some weird hacks and
rap to get around it I think I used to
actually also do something like that in
the past but I anyway it doesn't matter
and the point is you should never kind
of try and hack your way around this
it's super simple to get this timing
logic to work some people also like to
only run their own update function at a
certain restricted framerate so for
example independent of your screen
refresh rate or independent of vsync or
independent of your uncapped frame rate
on update runs 60 times per second and
that might give you and and because of
that you'll move like you don't need to
multiply anything by Delta time you can
move a certain amount inside or on your
on update function you can hard code it
to be that one unit for example or 0.01
or 0.1 or whatever you don't need to
keep multiplying by Delta time because
you can predict how far
that's not a good way of doing things
the reason that's not a good way of
doing things is because that's great if
your application is able to hit 60 but
what if your frame rate drops massively
what if you're on 10 frames per second
for a little bit because everything's
lacking well guess what the game is
actually physically gonna run slower
right which again my people you want but
probably isn't right especially if
you're talking about rendering graphics
you don't want everything to run slower
what you wanted said is to render less
frames now if you're suddenly at 10 FPS
right because you're just doing point 1
movement every second without Delta time
then in 10 in one second it's gonna move
a total of one unit whereas if you're
multiplying by Delta time the amount
that it'll move at 10 FPS in one at
second of real-world time will be the
same as in 60 FPS because it's just
gonna move in bigger jumps if that makes
sense right so for example said of the
smoothness you might just get three
frames like that but the point is the
object still takes the same amount of
time in real world time to move and
that's what you want right so if that
happens in your attend then this time
value would be 0.1 right and in other
words you multiply this by 0.1 and
suddenly it's a much bigger jump than if
you multiply by a smaller number and
your game ends up running the same speed
if the frame rate is below vsync right
and the only difference here is that you
just render less frames essentially you
don't actually take longer to do
anything which is usually what you want
okay so hopefully that makes sense
now we can actually dive into the code
and create this whole kind of Delta time
time step thing all right so to do this
as I said we basically need to pass in
into an update we need to pass in that
Delta time so let's talk a little bit
about how that's even going to work in
the first place so this run loop this is
the while loop in which we need to
measure how long this frame actually
takes right so over here would be a good
place to actually do that kind of
calculation now what I'm gonna do is
actually inside hazal inside I wanna
make a new folder called core and this
stuff is actually gonna have like a lot
of the core stuff that hazel has because
I don't know this is getting a little
bit flooded applications in here last I
don't know I'm gonna do a huge refactor
I think soon because I don't like how
masses
coming but it's like all I'm going to
just basically make a little header file
called time step and I called it Tim
step so that's fantastic time step okay
and this is gonna be a little bit of a
helper class for us basically we're
gonna make a class full time step it's
going to be didn't even make this as
struct if you wanted to honestly it
doesn't really matter but I'll still
make it a class we're gonna do time step
float time right
and then we'll basically hold time and
we'll set it to zero by default and
actually we don't need to set it to zero
by default we just have the constructor
set it and we can have a default
parameter so it will set time here and
then all we'll do is we'll have some
basic functions for retrieving the time
right you could do a whole bunch of
stuff here right you could for example
have like you know you can override
operator plus or plus equals or anything
so that you can increment time step that
way so that you can really just have a
wrapper around the float and we might do
that but for now we'll just have get
seconds which is going to return time
because our time is in seconds by
default and we'll have get in
milliseconds because that can be useful
as well
and that's just going to return time
times 1000 okay you could store the time
in milliseconds instead of seconds and
then you can just you know multiply by
0.001 to get it into seconds but I'm
gonna start in seconds from now so
that's how it's going to look and we
might add some other functions if we
need to I'm just thinking about it like
we subtracting might be useful and other
mathematical operators might be useful
but this is basically what we have for
now a very very basic time step class so
now what we're going to do is inside
application first of all I'm going to go
into hazel and make sure that this we
can put it here include hazel for time
step is here inside our application
class I'm going to include that as well
so include hazel for time step then
we're going to actually have a time step
here right so what we'll do is
inside here in a while this is an error
ah just probably just intellisense what
I'll do is and I should have had a
divider here private what I'll do is
I'll actually just have time step time
step okay and this time step and again
it depends if you want to do it this way
or if you don't want to do it this way
it's up to you I'm also gonna have a
little flirt actually I probably don't
have to have a time step here really no
I don't all I need is something called
last time right and last time which I'll
initialize to zero is going to be the
time that it took to round the last
frame I might say the last frame time
okay so this over here is going to be
updated every single frame
so we'll say time here and then what
we'll do here is actually retrieve the
time from our platform so lots of ways
to do this you could just use you know
windows basically to get the right time
by using something like query
performance counter that's a huge thing
we might actually do that in the future
but for now this is gonna be jealous
over yet time again now that does mean
that we tie this application class to
job W this is kind of temporary because
I don't want to make this video forever
but this should be in platform we should
have a platform class that is kind of
you know Windows platform Mac platform
whatever iOS platform Apple platform
whatever you want right all different
platforms that are going to have their
own implementations right but platform
get time should be a platform
independent way of actually getting the
time and if for Windows it would use gfw
get time but I don't really want to set
up the platform just yet because it's a
bit early to do that we could do it but
you know we're not going to today you
can do that yourself you want for
homework and we'll actually get around
to doing it when we have more things to
add into platform than just timing so
time zambezi little you get time which
returns time in seconds so I'm just
gonna cost that to a foot right and then
when I calculate Delta x so we'll say
time step time step equals time - and
last frame time
right and of course we don't we can just
assign it to a float like that because
we have a constructor that takes in a
float so it'll be an implicit cast that
is our Delta time that's our time step
right that's gonna be how long this
frame like what the current time is
versus the last frame time so we record
the last frame time we do our whole
frame then when we wrap around and get
back up to here we get the current time
again and we calculate the difference or
the Delta and that is how we get our
deltas name and then we're going to
layer on update we take in a time step I
40s now you can see that I'm not pausing
this by conscious reference or anything
like that doesn't need to be it's just
going to be copied because if you look
at time step it is a single float right
it is just a float it's gonna miss we
it's the same as passing a float right
and over here
when we actually created every frame
we're creating that object on the stack
it's just it's literally the same as
creating a float so I don't know some
people might be like oh you're creating
a class for this why are you doing that
why don't you have a flirt it's the same
right it's basically a float was just
some helper functions to make it more
readable now if you if you were using
Java I wouldn't do it this way because
if you create a new object in Java
you're creating it on the heap and that
is a whole different ballgame or in C
sharp right although in c-sharp you can
use instruct and that will be something
on the stack but anyway the idea is that
this is like totally fine but some
people might be a bit hesitant if that's
what it is right so we have our time
step we passed that into our layer stack
and then if we go to sandbox you'll see
that because we've enforced layers to
have time steps now we have to go into
an update and actually make sure that we
have our time our hazal time step yes
okay now let's take a look at if this
even worked so we'll say age said what
is it age 13 4 or something like that I
said let's just say I said trace
so we'll say Delta time 0 and then TS
get seconds right so this should give us
how many seconds it took and then we
might actually say whoops we might
actually say
seconds and then in brackets I might put
how many milliseconds it is just to test
out everything make sure that we have
both things working let's hit f5 see
what happens obviously the first time
around it's not going to be a hundred
percent accurate just because for the
first frame we don't actually have
anything recorded yet we also get a
bunch of compile errors so this needs to
be we guess we need to include this so
include case or or time step to try and
run that again because last frame time
by default is set to zero right so when
we do time - last frame time it's gonna
be the time since the last frame there
was no last frame so it's going to be
slightly inaccurate but that's normal
and that's totally fine I wouldn't worry
about it okay if we look at this now
look at what week well look at what we
get let's stop this so this is a sixty
Hertz monitor and vsync is enabled so
you can see that we get about sixteen
point about sixteen point like five six
seven whatever around sixteen point six
milliseconds per frame well zero point
zero one six seconds okay that's what we
get here that looks pretty good to me
now let's use this inside our actual
inside our actual math stuff here right
so when we actually do the camera
movement let's use this stuff so the way
we do that is you can just do em camera
move speed times TS don't get seconds
now you could we could do is just add an
operate like I add a float operator to
this so that you can cast it to a float
employ like implicitly and then you can
just do x ts like that that's probably
something that's worth doing to be
honest because I this API is okay but I
don't love it so the way that we do that
is we basically to say operate a float
and then we can just say return M time
right that it's that simple and of
course you can mark it as Const what
this does is it's like it's used for a
lot of things that you you can cause
things to ball that's done very
frequently as well so that we can just
if check something really easily that's
you know for example how share pointers
or unique point is you can actually
check to see if they've got a value just
by doing if and then the pointer there's
the smart pointer it is
we're just using float here and what
that says is you can basically use this
as a flirt it's basically like a static
cast operator that where you're actually
just adding the ability to cast
implicitly okay or to cast it all really
so when you when you do try and cast to
a float whether explicitly or implicitly
it will just return time that's what's
gonna happen right so you're adding like
a cast operator basically so if we go
back over here but what that means for
us is that instead of using TS we can
basically do cool stuff like float time
equals TDS right because we now have a
way to convert TS into a float and that
is by using this flow operator here now
again it's useful it's it's worth
mentioning the fact that in this case
it's gonna return seconds if your
milliseconds you have to ask for it and
in situations where you think it might
matter if you're using seconds or
milliseconds it is much better to just
use the actual function but you know
since we're basically saying that in
hazel by default time steps are always
gonna be in seconds and then
milliseconds is the non typical scenario
it's fine to just do this as long as you
make it clear obviously in your
documentation and in your code that this
is gonna give you seconds okay cool so
now we get rid of this and we just have
x ts and we have that everywhere okay
for any kind of movement and now all
this stuff is not tied to the speed of
our game running now what I want to do
before I do that is show you guys what
it was like before so if I don't do that
let's see what the problem is so
obviously if I run my code right now
I've got vsync turned on which means
that it's going to run at 60 times per
second and you could see that my delta
time was 60 per second in fact I might
go back to what we had before just so
that we can see that so if I just
controls that a whole bunch so that we
get back to this right and I hit f5
you'll see that what we actually end up
with is a time step of 0.16 seconds
right so over here well sorry 0.01 6
seconds right that's what we're at
because these things turned on now let's
go ahead and create a different story
for ourselves oh and one last thing that
I actually wanted to show you here is
you can see how fast the move
rotation is it's that fast right so if
we go into our application and I don't
remember if we created this API or not
yeah so we have set vsync right so if we
go back to application when we create
our window and actually set vsync to be
false right what that's gonna do is set
the GL FW swap interval to be zero right
and it should run a lot faster and we'll
see our actual kind of real frame rate
of how fast is able to render frames
because now it's gonna do it as fast as
possible and if we look at our time step
you can see it's a lot small it's like
three milliseconds right 0.003 okay I
think it's probably using the
intelligent vu or something like that
now that's using a video okay cool
so now if I try moving whoa look at that
that's suddenly it's so much faster
right that's the problem that I'm
talking about right we don't want this
we want it to be the same speed no
matter if we are vsync on or off right
so that's what we're trying to achieve
here so now if we multiply this with TS
right so I'll just grab this and copy
and paste it a bunch of times and I'll
get rid of this print thing now it's
gonna be multiplied by TS so no matter
how fast we run will always run at the
same speed it won't be like super slow
or super fast or anything it'll be at
the speed that we set it out now right
now it's gonna be super slower because
obviously our speed is quite slow right
so we've said that we're moving like 0.1
units per second or whatever that's
really quite slow so our camera move
speed will change to be 1 and our camera
rotation speed is 2 now we might make
that like 10 or something like that
remember this is in degrees so think
about how much you want it to rotate in
one second that's what this is coming
down to so we want it to rotate 10
degrees per second is that fine
is moving one unit per second fine right
think about that so I might say maybe
like 30 degrees per second or something
I don't know that might be too fast one
unit per second is probably gonna be too
slow as well but we can see so that's no
that's that rotation speeds actually
quite slow feeling so as the movement
speed let's bump
maybe to five and to 180 so maybe we can
it takes us a second to rotate 180
degrees that might be a little bit more
reasonable okay and you can see yep so
that takes about a second right to
rotate and our movement speed is a lot
faster okay so that depends like this
might be too fast for you might not be
but the idea is that you know remember
this speed right it's quite fast now
what I can do is go back to application
make sure we're not doing vsync so now
basing will be on right we're not
setting it to false anymore and now what
we should get is guess what the same
exact speed even though we're running
the update loop a lot less times now
like right like a lot less frequently
because we're only doing at CC times per
second instead of like how many ever
times we were doing it before okay so
you can see why time steps are important
and how we can use them really easy and
we've created a really nice API for us
that does everything for us again could
have just been a float but this is a lot
more powerful and will probably expand
this in the future when we want to do
more advanced things with our time step
you know I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did you can hit a like
button but you can also help support the
series but grant a patron confession the
cherry huge thank you as always to all
the lovely patrons to make this series
possible hope that was kind of
informative about what Delta time what
time steps are in game engines and in
games in general I think that it's a
very very very simple topic that is
often like glossed over it's often kind
of glossed over it's often just like
disregarded and just like you know
whatever let's just Jamison it's not
important or it might it's such a
complicated with timing that's probably
so complicated there's math involved you
know let's just not do it
whereas it's just so simple right and
it's so simple it's so powerful it makes
your game run properly on no matter what
framerate or refresh rate you're running
on right if I now want to play this game
of mine on a monitor this high that has
like 120 544 Hertz 240 Hertz it's
actually gonna render more frames
properly like it's actually gonna run
properly and you'll see that smooth
effect and all we had to do which is a
little bit of maths
and a little bit of timing logic like
three lines of just time right really
easy stuff that's kind of what I want
this game engine series to be about
right just showing you guys how simple
it is how a lot of these things are so
simple and easy to do now in the next
episode I want to kind of talk about
object transforms because at the moment
we have a camera that's fantastic but
what if I want to render like three
different objects three different like
squares that we have here are three
different triangles at different
positions on the screen I can't actually
do that at the moment but I want to be
able to do that so we'll cover that next
time and then we might move on to more
exciting things like just graphics
related things I think again because I
mean there's a lot of stuff to cover
early but I think you next time we're
going to do deal with object transforms
and see how actually we tell our
renderer where on the screen we want to
render a particular object now in the
future when we move to like an empty
component system or some kind of like
composable game object so any kind of
like system that actually deals with
entities or game objects they're gonna
have their own transform component and
then that's gonna kind of feed into the
renderer eventually but for now we're
gonna have a more simple system that
just lets us arrange stuff but anyway
we'll talk more about that in the next
video thank you for watching goodbye
[Music]